-Thank you so much
for joining us in studio, buddy.
It's always good to see you.
Have you been able to move into
the new house yet?
-Yeah, man.
This is my first, like, time
living in an actual house,
and it's scary.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. What do you mean?
Because you're used to what?
Apartments?
-Well, I'm used to noise,
I'm used to, like, ambulances
and fire trucks and all that.
[ Laughter ]
-That calms you down?
-Yeah! This is, like, scary
when you hear
just your house make noise.
[ Laughter ]
There's like this ice maker
in the fridge thing or whatever,
and every time,
in the middle of the night,
when it's very still --
[ Audience member groans ]
-You know what
I'm talking about, right?
[ Cheers ]
I always think I'm being robbed
by, like, The Three Stooges.
[ Laughter ]
It sounds like someone falling
down the stairs every time.
It's scary.
-You're being robbed
by The Three Stooges.
-Yeah, it's always loud
and clumsy.
-[ Laughs ]
-But it's cool, it's cool.
-Congratulations, bud.
I'm so happy for you.
Last time you were on the show,
you were here with Colin Jost,
and then, a few weeks later,
he got married.
-Allegedly.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, don't say that.
-I still don't buy it, man.
-You were --
-He married Scarlett Johansson!
How's that possible? What?
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't think she knows
she's Scarlett Johansson.
[ Laughter ]
-Last time, you were saying that
you were gonna make a speech --
-I wanted to. I wanted to, like,
interrupt the wedding.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So if somebody said,
"Does anyone object with this?"
you were gonna stand up
and do your speech
and ruin his wedding.
-Yeah.
-Did you?
-No, I didn't.
Well, I had all these --
I wanted to.
I didn't have the courage.
-Yeah, good.
Smart.
-I had all of these pictures
of The Rock that I was gonna
send her, and be like,
"You could marry The Rock."
[ Laughter ]
I still don't believe it.
I still think, at some point,
this is just, like, one long
Sacha Baron Cohen bit.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys are great
on "Weekend Update" together.
I do love this one bit you do
where you make Colin
read jokes that you wrote.
-Yeah.
-And he makes you read --
I mean, this is the best thing
I've ever seen.
-Yeah, we call it "Joke Swap."
-A joke swap.
But I mean like, this --
How did that start?
-It was actually his idea,
which was kind of funny,
because I thought
he was trying to prank me.
See, I'm paranoid.
[ Laughter ]
-I think everything's a prank.
Right now,
I think this is all a prank.
But he was like, "Hey,
why don't we do something
where, like,
you write jokes for me,
I write jokes for you,
and we don't know
till we get on air?"
And I'm like,
"Oh, you trying to set me up."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So I started thinking of, like,
some really racist things
for him to say,
'cause I'm like...
[ Laughter ]
..."You not gonna get me.
You gonna catch some fire
coming in the door."
-Yeah, of course.
-And then we got on the air,
and a lot of his jokes
are kind of tame.
-And just nice,
and all yours are --
-And all of mine was just,
like, about Rosa Parks.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Oh, oh, okay.
That's one way to do it."
-Oh, my --
I mean, dude, his face,
you could just see him sweating.
-It was bright red,
and Black people loved it.
It's awesome.
[ Laughter ]
-It was just announced
that Elon Musk
is gonna host "SNL" May 8th.
Are you --
With Miley Cyrus, by the way.
-Yeah, no,
it's gonna be great.
-That's a big show.
Are you excited to meet him?
-I am excited to meet him.
I don't know if he knows,
like -- usually, like,
we have this tradition --
I don't know, I think it's
in the book or whatever --
but at "Saturday Night Live,"
it's customary for hosts
to give, like, a couple million
dollars to the cast members.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Wow.
-Yeah, I don't know if he's --
if he's a cool guy,
maybe he'll...
-Keep up that tradition.
-Yeah, maybe.
-Yeah, that's so smart.
See, that's smart, yeah.
-He's going to Mars, man.
He doesn't need all that money.
-Would you ever go to space?
-No, not on purpose.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. How would you get there
on accident?
-I don't know.
-Go to L.A., next thing
you're like,
"Wait. Is that Earth?"
[ Laughter ]
-No, yeah, I don't know.
I wouldn't.
Would you?
-I thought about it.
No.
-If the richest man in the world
is going, would you go?
-No.
-Okay.
-I'd go maybe, like,
the year after
the richest man in the world.
[ Light laughter ]
-I'll go when they build
a CVS there.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Until that, no.
-Yeah, until they have a CVS,
I don't trust it.
-I want to talk about this show
on HBO Max.
I'm so psyched
that you made this.
It's called
"That Damn Michael Che."
-Yeah.
-Which is so funny
even just saying that title,
because the audience was like,
"Why would you say that
about Michael Che?"
-That's why I like it!
Because it could go either way.
It could be like, "Man,
that damn Michael Che is funny,"
or it could be,
"That damn Michael Che."
[ Laughter ]
I like the kind of weight of it.
-It's great.
What is it like?
What do you compare it to?
-I wanted to call it
"That Black-Ass Michael Che."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, okay, yeah.
-But HBO said no.
-No, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it sketch?
Is it stand-up?
What is it?
-It's like loose kind of jokes.
-Yeah.
-And then there's also
some sketches.
And it's just fun, you know?
It's like six episodes.
[ Laughter ]
-I want everyone to watch.
-Yeah, I want everybody
to watch it.
Please, watch it!
It's fun.
-Make sure you get on this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
HBO, HBO Max.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Michael Che...
-You got a clip?
-...in his new show --
Yeah, you got a clip.
You never come on with a clip.
-No, it's so weird to be out
here to promote something.
-Yeah, you never are.
-No, I'm not.
I'm just hanging out with you.
-Wait. This is history.
We're actually
throwing to a clip.
-Yeah, this is crazy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is a big deal.
-I'm on the "The Tonight Show,"
going to a clip.
-Yeah.
Here's Michael Che
in his new show,
"That Damn Michael Che."
Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I just want to say I'm sorry.
-Oh, it's -- it's cool.
I could barely smell it.
-What?
Oh, no, not that.
Um, I mean,
I'm sorry for everything
going on in the country.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
With the police shootings
and all the injustices.
And for white privilege.
-This thing even move yet?
-I'm an ally, obviously,
so I'm not trying to be weird.
-Think it's supposed
to light up if it's moving.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Stuck on an elevator.
[ Laughs ]
Michael Che, everybody!
All episodes of
"That Damn Michael Che" are
streaming May 6th on HBO Max.